I love what you two are doing with this
house but what are you gonna do with
five bedrooms you guys are obviously
never having kids
what was that look I did not do a look
you're doing a look right now there's no
look have a good fight guys there's so
many kids in foster care and they're
having an orientation value people who
taken foster kids are really special the
kind of people who volunteer when it's
not even a holiday we don't even
volunteer on a holiday are currently in
foster care the county puts these on
because they can match a lot of kids and
parents quickly they're teenagers okay
maybe's drugs and they watch people
playing video games on YouTube they're
not equipped for any of that
hey this FYI we can all hear you hmm
okay go mingle with the kiddies and
don't give it another thought
bye bye she was cool Lizzy it comes with
two younger siblings three kids too much
oh my god why would you show us that
that's wrong here we make yourself at
home
because you're at home do you like more
of a Lakers fan I think the Clippers are
awesome they were smart for trading
Blake Griffin your best player to the
fire department comes okay you're just
another white lady who wants to adopt
charity orphans make you feel good about
yourself Tenenbaums we might have a
little bit of a knack for this oh I beg
to differ
this stuff takes time busy the parent
wanted Lita all by herself are going to
be easy but with some structure and love
you could make your house a home
we love you please go away hello mister
you know what I'd like to do
let me fix it okay
what are you doing in my phone looking
with this boy texted her future you
security I'll end your life right now
paratah I'm gonna call your mom you're
going down to dangle what do you think
of that chicken what Lizzy's mom is a
product of the system and she never
learned to properly care for herself
much less three kids three kids oh yeah
three yeah once yeah
Lizzy comes with two younger siblings
one and Lita wait wait so we would have
three children
Oh - maybe but there's no way we can do
three I mean that was we wanted to me oh
my gosh
why would you show us that why would you
even show that they're so cute that's
wrong but listen we wouldn't recommend
this match if we didn't believe that
with some structure and love these these
kids could blossom right yeah and we're
hoping to get them out of their current
foster placement Muskies might lose that
meal ticket Karen please
most of our foster parents are really
terrific caring people and yes there are
people who do it just for the paycheck
but the Muskies are not abusive or evil
just maybe a little
Ambria Karen there is no immunity no I
swear they look like brother-sister I
can't tell them apart hey hon hey how's
she doing she's good oh yeah check this
out I got here early and Lizzie saw me
and she came over and just starts
talking to you yeah
[Music]
whatever did you hear that
it's got my first daddy what am I gonna
look like you reckon I look like a
beautiful print so do I look like a
flower mom no no no it's totally
washable it's um that's a sharpie oh
yeah it's a big huge giant deal 15 yo
girls should never be making ever you
don't show me something soon I might
lose interest
what Oh hit this person Lizzy we are
going in a living room I'm so excited
you excited I just kept worried but you
think things are gonna be easier than
they actually are what I do not you tell
this whole thing was your idea
now I'm pumped about it you're not even
pumped well you don't look pumping a big
life-altering moment like this you gotta
get pumped we're about to do something
insane did you hear her speak was the
greatest thing I've ever heard in my
life
come on cowgirl let me get a yeehaw no
beau anyone louder crazy come on
well we have been talking for a long
time about whether or not we wanted to
have kids
and I just made this joke of like kind
of starting to feel on the old side of
it why don't we just adopt a
five-year-old and it'll be like I got
started five years ago and she
immediately said you know I would really
consider that and I said yeah I was
really joking
once we decided to move forward it was
scary and overwhelming but we were
really open to whatever came our way we
went through some really tough times the
kids adjusting to us are suggesting to
them but not just adjusting to them but
just adjusting to being parents in
general because we went from zero kids
to three kids literally overnight I felt
like so much of what we went through was
funny so I thought yeah couldn't we make
a comedy that really shows how this
really works more of a Lakers fan
[Music]
Clippers are awesome they were smart for
trading Blake Griffin the best player
when I started talking about making it
into a movie I wanted it to be as much
of our story as possible but I also sat
down with a bunch of other families
particularly those who had adopted
teenage girls
the support group was cracking up
actually when upping us with things that
their kids at 17 - yeah it's rare to
have that honesty and in a lot of things
today I'm just so proud of him
the idea isn't for people to see the
movie on them run out and adapt kids I
mean that would be wonderful but I feel
like when people have biological kids
it's very very easy to picture babies
and little league and graduation and
prom but when people think about kids in
foster care they're thinking ahead of
all the sort of hard parts and what the
movie does is it does start with those
hard parts but it also shows what's
funny about those hard parts then it
takes you through to when you become
more of a family and hopefully it'll
demystify all that and you'll just
realize that they're just family and
that could even be you that could even
be your kids and your family you guys
are obviously never having kids
did not do a look you're doing a look
right now there's no have a good fight
guys there's so many kids in foster care
adoption I just got home from work we
found a great match for you guys most
folks want nothing to do with teenagers
st. use drugs and they watch people
playing video games on YouTube i FY i we
can all hear you hmm
okay let me go with the kitties and
don't give it another thought bye bye
she was cool she comes with two younger
siblings one and you ten three kids too
much why would you show us that
what are we supposed to say no to that
now
make yourself at home and I'm not saying
we're perfect parents should we give
them a kiss goodbye but we might have a
little bit of a knack for this are you
sure
keep in mind folks it is not it's gonna
be easy mom honey that's a marker let's
gonna do the product a week
oh yeah these kids will test your will I
put it 150 games of candy lane with Lena
you ever play for concave eel and it's
brutal very dull and push-button
you didn't know your hand we could have
just picked a toddler he doesn't have
opinions and fall underwear what are you
wearing
sorry you know dress like an upstate
douche like you hey this is real
cashmere
no but with some structure and love
these kids could blossom let me fix it
everything's gonna be okay
[Music]
taking naked selfies of herself
honey what exactly is a dick pic Jesus
that is a trout you said your Jacob
you're lucky I'll end your life right
now carrot top we're gonna call your mom
you're going down to tango what do you
think of that Jacob my name is not Jacob
what
[Music]
what makes your hands special or unique
they get really good they're always
trying to put on this happiest face
they're like my role models they're both
very complete dorks like me what are
your favorite things to do with your dad
like chicks on my mom we do a lot my mom
cooks the best food when I eat all that
food if you have like a best or favorite
memory yes memory when we got adopted if
your parents were in this room right now
what would you want to say to them thank
you for bringing me into their family or
doing anything for them
I really thank them for giving me the
best situation when I did not have the
best they chose me and they could assign
oh but they said yes to have me and I
was really happy about that
it made me feel special are you doing a
job interview we committed to being a
family or always in each other's hearts
so anyone that we love is really a part
of the family before you I really wasn't
anybody's mom and you did that for me
well and I'm not that big of a dork in
the destoyed the end
[Music]